- Yes, give him anything.
We need to stop,
his nervous system is falling, no, Fauci,
(glass shatters)
Chest compressions.
I'm about to play, "Bio Inc Redemption."
I couldn't play it before,
cause I didn't have a computer.
I had a computer, but not a PC.
I'm a Mac guy.
So, I got myself a Predator Triton 500.
It sounds like a transformer.
The fans are blowing,
cause my turbo button's on
and I'm overclocking.
Don't know what any of that means.
Sounds legit though.
(whooshing)
Choose death and explore your dark side
by wrathfully terminating victims.
Choose life and heroically
save your patient
before it's too late.
Shall I cross over to the dark side?
I don't know why I'm doing this.
I'm gonna save death for the end.
I'm gonna choose life first.
I wanna see what that's like.
Who needs a tutorial?
I'm a doctor.
This is a bio game.
I'm a bio life scientist,
I have a bio life site.
I have a Bio Life Sciences
Bachelor's degree.
So I should know how to play this game
without a tutorial on life.
We strongly advise for you
to complete the short life tutorial,
to learn the basics on
how to save your patients.
(yells) I've never skipped
a tutorial in my life.
In fact, I'm the guy that's
always judging people
for skipping the tutorial,
or throwing away the instructions,
when I'm like, just
follow the instructions.
It's so easy.
No.
Name your patient.
You know who's old?
Who we desperately need to keep around.
Who's actually been on this channel.
Dr.Fauci.
Patient, Dr. Fauci has a few diseases
targeting his circulatory
and nervous systems.
And his overall health is suffering.
Reach a hundred percent recovery
by diagnosing and treating diseases.
Okay.
His heart is bleeding and
this is not realistic,
but how..
Oh my God.
I probably should have
watched the tutorial.
What am I clicking on?
Oh no.
I should have watched the tutorial.
(ominous music)
He's bleeding.
He's muscular.
Fauci, you been lifting bro?
I don't understand.
I don't...
God I should have watched instructions.
All right.
We're gonna have to put a
fast diagnosis on Dr. Fauci
and figure out what's going on here.
New symptom confusion.
Oh no.
Dr. Fauci has altered mental status.
His nervous system's failing.
Let's work up his brain MRI.
I feel like a brain MRI
would give us some knowledge
about what's going on.
Brain MRI, test results,
hypertension positive.
First of all,
a brain MRI does not tell
you Someone's blood pressure.
Blood clots positive,
stroke positive,
Parkinson's positive.
And you got all those
results from a brain MRI.
A lot of inaccuracies here,
but we gotta treat the stroke quickly.
Okay, here we go.
Yoga will help him with his nervous system
and muscular system.
We don't have enough points.
We need two more points.
All right, we have six.
Let's get him to do some yoga.
Dr. Fauci is now practicing yoga.
Perfect.
That's a good warrior stance.
That is a good warrior stance.
(whooshing)
In critical condition,
Dr. Fauci has been admitted
to the emergency room.
No, no, no.
I'm not gonna let his
nervous system go down.
Intensive care nervous system evolve.
Dr. Fauci is receiving an experimental
neuro-regeneration therapy.
We need to give him TPA.
He's having a stroke.
Oh no, he's having leg pain.
Don't worry Dr. Fauci,
those are just light cramps.
Those are just light cramps.
The circulatory system is
also failing rather quickly.
What can I do?
Should I do more of a diagnosis?
Where's the circulatory system,
I don't see it.
Oh, we can make them into
a fitness enthusiast.
Dr. Fauci is now working
out several hours a week.
Look at this guy.
Dr. Fauci is training
for his first triathlon.
Wow.
While circulatory system
is failing and his nervous system.
Probably not a good idea,
that's all right.
Man his nervous system's
at 8%, just hang with me.
It was cause in the beginning
I didn't know what to do.
6%, no, Fauci,
(glass shatters)
Chest compressions.
We could give him psychiatric counseling
Yeah boy.
Stress management therapy.
No, he needs antidepressants.
No, I need three points
for antidepressants.
Gimme, gimme, gimme,
gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme.
(groans)
Okay, I think I can give
him antidepressants now.
Where are you?
Antidepressants.
(whooshing)
Prescribed.
Let's see if his nervous
system stabilizes a little bit.
Okay, it's getting better.
It's getting better.
Oh, he has memory loss now.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh my God he's at 4%.
1.4%.
2%, oh my God.
No Fauci, Fauci, Fauci, Fauci.
Just a little longer.
(game chimes)
Dr. Fauci is drinking alcohol responsibly.
Okay, that's good.
Cholinesterase inhibitors.
Yes, give him anything
We need to stop,
his nervous system is failing.
No.
Come on, come on.
Just hang on, man.
Oh, it's circulatory system failed.
Oh no.
He's bleeding,
Come on Fauci,
Come on.
America needs you.
The world needs you.
Brain MRI,
Oh, there's the...
Oh, I don't have enough.
Give him aspirin.
I don't have enough.
I could have given him
TPA this whole time,
dude, I didn't know.
I probably should have done the tutorial.
Give him anti-coagulants.
Yeah.
Give him alpha blockers.
He has paralysis now.
He's at 1%.
I think I'm gonna lose Fauci.
He's flat lining,
chest compressions.
(sighs)
Parkinson's disease caused
Dr. Fauci's nervous system
to collapse first,
which then led his circulatory
system to collapse.
(somber piano music)
Fauci.
We should have started on someone silly.
Oh my God, my nose is bleeding.
Look how sad I am for Fauci.
(snickers)
(beep)
We're gonna do that again.
Now that I know what I'm doing.
I'm thinking Tiger King.
Should we go Joe Exotic?
Or we should go Carroll Baskin?
It's sad.
But I'm about to save Joe Exotic
better than I did Dr. Fauci.
I should have probably
started with Joe Exotic.
Oh boy.
This is not gonna go well.
I'm gonna to build up all the bio points
and then right away
we're gonna start improving his lifestyle.
Let's get Joe Exotic
to relax a little bit.
He's a little wound up.
Let's get him doing a little Yoga.
Let's start the diagnosis.
He has some muscle weakness.
Muscle weakness can be a
sign of like kidney stuff.
So let's look at kidney stuff.
Let's do a urinalysis.
Let's do huh a full physical exam.
Let's see if he actually has weakness.
I need the results.
He has no gastroenteritis.
He has no muscle cramps
and he has no androgenic alopecia.
That is male pattern baldness.
Let's give him another work up
for his muscles and run a metabolic panel.
No sepsis, no kidney failure.
No UTI,
No Alport syndrome.
It's very specific.
Can't see, can't pee.
Look it up if you don't believe me.
Okay.
No cholesterol,
no potassium deficiency,
no diabetes,
no pancreatitis,
no hemophilia.
This is a healthy guy right here.
His nervous system's failing.
What conditions can
cause the nervous system
and the circulatory system
to fail simultaneously?
That's interesting.
Oh, a stroke.
Let's get a a brain MRI
in here and run tests.
(game chimes)
Oh, Parkinson's disease.
Makes a lot of sense.
No stroke.
No aneurysm though.
So we need to give him
carbidopa and levodopa.
Okay, and then I really wanna figure out
what's going on with
his circulatory system.
So let's go ahead
and run a blood pressure test
and see if he has high blood pressure.
Oh, he has high blood pressure.
We should treat that.
New disease found, hypertension.
Let's give him alpha blockers.
They're gonna be more
effective and quicker.
Man, he's going down quick.
(blood sloshes)
Personality changes?
Let's run the EKG
cause his circulatory system
is failing way too quick
for my liking.
(screen whooshing)
No, he's not having a heart attack.
What is going on with his heart?
Let's boost his circulatory system here.
Evolved.
Joe Exotic had a heart transplant.
His health increased by 25%.
Thank God.
But now his muscles are failing.
We need to find another disease.
Muscular, muscular, muscular.
Where are we?
Here we go.
FFMA test.
Fibromyalgia.
No way he has fibromyalgia
and he's dying from it.
That's not a deadly illness.
And now he has an irregular heartbeat.
(sighs)
How am I supposed to keep him alive?
(groans)
He's in the emergency room.
Come on, we're just gonna
run a bunch of tests.
We need to figure out
what's wrong with him.
(screen whooshing)
He doesn't have fibromyalgia.
None of the muscular diseases make sense.
Either that's of an
insomnia or hemiparesis.
Then why is he dying?
I can't think and click at the same time.
What other tests can I run?
Infectious disease thing.
Let's do some chest X-rays?
Can I slow the game down?
Okay, he's not having any lung issues.
He has no infectious disease.
What is going on?
What do you have?
Oh, no, his systems are failing.
(blood sloshes)
(game chimes)
I've run...
Oh no, no!
(beep)
No, my game exited.
I got it back.
What do you have Joe Exotic?
I just, I can't.
I've done every test.
What is male?
Let's do ultrasounds.
(chimes)
Okay, he has blood clots.
He has blood clots.
We can treat those
and he has testicular cancer.
Oh no.
Oh no, they wanna take away his testicles.
Okay, all right.
We did the testicles.
Let's see if he could survive.
Oh no, he died.
Joe!
- I'm never going to
financially recover from this.
(beep)
- Baskin, I'm going for the Baskin.
Carol Baskin.
Now I know,
I know you gotta diagnose right away
or you gotta put all your efforts
into making him as healthy as possible.
Or her as healthy as possible.
Her circulatory system is the worst,
followed by nervous system.
I know what to think now.
And I'm gonna start with the female.
Psychological evaluation.
(snickers) She clearly needs it.
(screen whooshing)
(game chimes)
She has chronic stress
and a nervous breakdown,
probably cause she killed her husband.
We give her stress management therapy.
We're gonna give her
psychiatric counseling.
All right, now let's run some tests.
Let's do a blood pressure.
Metabolic panel and a
neurological exam run test.
She has hypertension.
Let's open bio map, hypertension.
We would wanna treat that,
but we have no points.
So, let's collect some points.
She has high cholesterol.
We can treat that too.
And we can upgrade and we
can harvest faster now.
See, now I'm learning
how to play this game.
All for Carl, Carl Baskin.
Her name is not Carl Baskin.
I have a feeling I'm gonna save her.
I need 18 points for her
to have good genetics.
Cause I feel like then we can get her
across the finish line.
All right, here we go.
We have enough to get her good genetics.
Oh no, her nervous system is failing.
Let's do a brain MRI.
(screen whooshing)
Oh, she has a stroke and
blood clot and Parkinson's.
How do we treat it?
Let's see if we can treat her Parkinson's.
I can't treat her Parkinson's,
What about the stroke?
We can treat the stroke.
Yes.
Oh, she's in the emergency room.
We need to get three more points
and then we could probably save here.
Here we go.
Come on, we gotta be able to help her out.
Oh my God, the nervous
system's still failing.
(sighs) Maybe it's
something with the females,
do a mammogram,
but that wouldn't affect
her nervous system.
What else can I check?
I'm trying everything.
Oh, she has breast cancer.
That was the most excited
I've ever been about that diagnosis?
I don't think she's gonna-
(sighs)
She's at 65%.
If I just help her a little bit.
Everything's coming up negative.
That's the problem.
Oh my God. She's falling apart.
Oh no, oh no.
Let's see, female pelvic exam run test.
(game chimes)
A-ha, she has polycystic ovarian syndrome,
which we're going to treat
with oral contraceptives.
I just don't understand
what she could have.
Maybe I'm playing this too medically.
Oh no, she's in pain.
She's suffering.
I'm desperate.
Cause I don't know how to help her.
She doesn't have any of these symptoms.
She died.
I don't know how to play this,
and she died faster
than everyone else died.
She had Parkinson's disease,
but I looked for Parkinson's disease,
I don't get it,
(sad horn music)
I think basically what I have to do
is play the death version of this game.
So if you want me to play the
death version of this game,
get this video to a hundred thousand likes
and check out me playing, "Plague Inc."
I actually created a virus
very similar to COVID-19
and check out this video here,
where I played, "Sims."
but I made myself in the game
and bear and try to go through med school,
which one you clicking on?
As always stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat hiphop music)